[Musik]
[Applaus]
ausgerückten Truppe meldet die
Militärmusik Oberösterreich eine
ehrenkomponie gestellt durch die Garde
denn Insignien Truppen Luftunterstützung
sowie Abordnungen der Verbände und
unmittelbaren Einheiten
Luftunterstützung zum feierlichen
Jubiläum angetreten
für die Meldung mit dem Festakt beginnen
mit dem Festakt beginnen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vegetier Wolfgang Gutenberger Herr präge
dir bitte über ihre Worte
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren fertig
Geistlichkeit als Kommandant der
Luftunterstützung ist es mir eine
besondere Freude sie heute im Rahmen des
Festaktes 20 Jahre C130 Hercules im
österreichischen Bundesheer am
fliegerhorst-
die Wichtigkeit des operativen
lufttransportsystems für die luft-
Hauptmanns von Oberösterreich den
Landesrat für Soziales Integration und
Jugend
Herrn Dr Wolfgang hartmannsdorfer in
unserer Mitte begrüßen zu dürfen
[Applaus]
in Vertretung des Herrn
generalstoffchefs darf ich den Leiter
der Direktion 2 und er tiefbringer
begrüßen
[Applaus]
mein respektvoller Gruß gilt den
Vertretung des Leiters der Direktion
eins Herrn general major Gerhard
Christina
[Applaus]
einen herzlichen Willkommensgruß
entbiete ich dem Leiter der
luftzugabteilung Herrn brigittier
Magister Jörg
[Applaus]
für die Direktion 7 freut es mich
besonders
[Applaus]
im Vertretung des Vorsitzenden des
Fachausschusses Luft begrüße ich Herrn
Peter hernegger
[Applaus]
für den Bezirkshauptmann Linz Land darf
ich den Leiter der Sicherheitsabteilung
Herrn Magister Dietmar tasni begrüßen
den Kommandanten des Jagdkommandos Herr
brigittier Magister Philipp secure
[Applaus]
aus dem Bereich der luftschekräfte darf
ich weiters willkommen heißen den Leiter
des materialstabs Luft Herrn Brigadier
Diplom-Ingenieur Peter Wessely den
Kommandanten der luftrömerwachung Herrn
Oberst Markus Kronreif und den
Kommandanten der Flieger und
fliegerarbeitenschule ein brigidier
Magister Reinhard Kraft herzlich
willkommen
[Applaus]
für die Direktion 2 freut es mich den
Chef des Stabes und stellvertreten
Kommandant
[Applaus]
des Bürgermeisters unserer
Heimatgemeinde von Hörsching begrüße ich
ein Gemeinderat Robert roitmeyer
[Applaus]
Einsätze Logan Einsätze unserer C130
Flotte auf mehreren Kontinenten in
hervorragender Weise und ohne
luftfahrzeugverluste gelangen und auch
zukünftig gelingen werden denn für sie
alle den heutigen Kommandanten der
ausgerückten Truppe und Kommandanten der
fliegertechnischen Kompanie 130 ein
Oberstleutnant
[Applaus]
ich vertraue darauf dass sie diesen
Arbeitseifer und das hohe persönliche
Engagement auch weiterhin zum Wohle der
Luftunterstützung und des
österreichischen Bundesheers einbringen
werden
abschließend darf ich mich bei Ihnen
allen sehr verehrte Damen und Herren für
die in den letzten 20 Jahren gelebte
Unterstützung beim unfallfreien Betrieb
der 1030 Herkules bedanken und sehr
suchen auch die Zukunft des operativen
lufttransportsystems im österreichischen
Bundesheer gemeinsam mit uns zu planen
und zu gestalten damit wir weiterhin die
an uns gestellten Aufgaben zeitgerecht
und mit größter Präzision als Beitrag zu
einem lebenswerten und sicheren Umfeld
in Österreich und Europa erfüllen können
[Applaus]
der fliegermarsch kerzengrad steige ich
zum Himmel 1912 komponiert vom
Österreicher Hermann Dostal und jetzt
gespielt von der Militärmusik
Oberösterreich kündigt die Ansprache des
militärischen höchstanwesenden Leiter
der Direktion 2 und Kommandanten der
luftschwerkräfte Brigitte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hochwertige Geistlichkeit geschätzte
Herr Landesrat dr hartmannsdorfer sehr
geehrte Personalvertretung sehr geehrte
Festgäste
Soldatinnen Soldaten und
Zivilbedienstete
parts and friends herzlich willkommen
hier im Fliegerhorst Vogler in Hörsching
als erste von drei für das
österreichische Bundesheer bestimmten
C130 Hercules Transportflugzeuge landete
ziemlich genau vor 20 Jahren am 20 März
2003 die eight tengo Charlie Alpha in
Österreich einen Tag darauf wurde sie
auch offiziell in den Dienst gestellt
und die zweite Maschine die etango
Charlie Charlie hier zu bewundern die da
entsprechend dargestellt ist traf am 26
August in Linz Hörsching ein und am 28
Februar in weiter Folge der dritte
Maschine
die mit der C130 Hercules erhielt das
österreichische Bundesheer eine eigene
Lufttransport Kapazität nachdem wir
jahrzehntelang uns mit teuren
Notlösungen abfinden mussten die drei
Maschinen wurden bereits in den Jahren
sage und schreibe 1976
korrigiere 67 und 68 von der Royal Air
Force
angeschafft und waren auf der Royal Air
for Station leinham stationiert von dort
flogen sie Einsätze in den focklands
auch im Zuge des vorkenntskonflikt ein
Anfang der 80er Jahre sowie auch bei der
Operation
in Irak
sie waren bei Lieferung somit schon über
35 Jahre alt und hatten um die 25.000
Flugstunden absolviert und die Royal Air
Force selbst ersetzte diese drei
Maschinen durch modernere Systeme
die drei Transport
Luftfahrzeuge wurden bei der
Auslieferung von der Firma marschlof
Cambridge Aerospace limited
generalüberholt und abgegradet
das Systempreis Bezug damals um die 40
Millionen Euro für diese drei
generalüberholten überholten Maschinen
die Ausbildungskosten das Information
des erforderliche
logistikpaket Ersatzteile und Zubehör
und die weitere Betreuung wurde
einerseits durch die Royal Air Force
auch gebaut mit der schwedischen
Luftwaffe und mit Marschall of Cambridge
ebenfalls das war alles in diesem Paket
enthalten das heißt eine einzelne neue
C130 zum damaligen Zeitpunkt kostete 80
Millionen Euro
der Kauf von neuen Systemen gab das
landesverteilungsbudget einfach nicht
her es war nicht abbildbar somit griff
man auf gebrauchte Maschinen zurück und
die Finanzierung erfolgte sich in den
letzten 20 Jahren bewährt und ist bis
heute die Nabelschnur für unsere
Soldaten in den auslandskontingenten am
Balkan
im Libanon in Mali und bald auch in
Niger
ich möchte die außergewöhnlichen
Leistungen der luftfahrzeugbesatzungen
der lufttransportstaffel unseren
Technikern der fliegertechnischen
Kompanie unseren Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern des Lufttransport Umschlags
weil die Fracht muss ja auch
entsprechend geparkt werden der
planungszelle operativer Lufttransport
im Flieger auch dispatch genannt und das
Kommandos Luftunterstützung entsprechend
hervorheben
nur mit einem eigenen
lufttransportsystem sind wir
entsprechend unabhängig und in der Lage
unsere Soldaten und Soldaten im Ausland
zu versorgen aber auch im andersfall
österreichische und EU-Staatsbürger und
StaatsbürgerInnen zu evakuieren
wie wir es auch im Zuge des arabischen
Frühlings aus Ägypten gemacht haben seit
der systemeführung der C130 Hercules in
Österreich wurden ca 17.000 Flugstunden
absolviert wir haben in Summe und das
danke auch für die exakte Dokumentation
117.584 Passagiere transportiert fast
1,5 Millionen Tonnen an Cargo und
Versorgungsgütern ins Ausland
transportiert und
13.670 Staats und zum Glück auch
Landungen hingelegt das heißt eine
exzellente Leistung wie vom Konrad
Luftunterstützung angesprochen vom
gesamten operativen lufttransportsystem
hervorzuhebene Einsätze des
lufttransportsystems Herkules waren
2004 der Ersteinsatz der im Zuge des
Tsunami in Sri Lanka das war die erste
Bewährungsprobe gleichzeitig 2004 die
Unterstützung nach dem Terrorangriff im
Islam
2009 und dann haben wir wirklich mein
absoluter Respekt für den damals jungen
staffelkommandanten
damals hat man Armin Kriegl und seinen
Mannen für die folgeversorgung und erst
ein Satz im Chat wo allein pro Jahr 1200
Flugstunden für die EU-Mission geflogen
wurden kamen es wurde dreimal in der
Woche wurden Versorgungsgüter und
Soldaten des akkumanders in den
Einsatzraum geflogen Folge versorgt und
bedarf soll wieder sicher nach Hause
gebracht
weiters 2011 im Zuge des Europa des
arabischen Frühlings haben wir
österreichische und EU-Staatsbürger aus
dem Maghreb-Staaten evakuiert es war
interessant wie ich dann die Passagiere
entsprechend begrüßt habe in Wien
Schwechat die sich über mangeln
Sitzkomfort beschwert haben dass sie
lieber mit aus den Airlines geflogen
werden ich verstehe die überhaupt die
Beschwerden nicht
weiters haben sie gefragt ob sie nicht
beim nächsten Flug dabei sein können
weil sie möchten noch gerne eine
Trekkingtour machen
und jetzt erst kürzlich 20 20 23 der
Afro Einsatz nach dem Erdbeben in der
Türkei
die C130 Hercules flog seit auch wie sie
hier hinten sehen diesen weißen
Container mit dem Roten Kreuz ein
entsprechendes aerome medical evocation
Modul kurz melde Weg Modul für das
lufttransportsystem Herkules C130 das
befähigt uns verletzte und erkrankte
Österreicher und Österreicher sowie auch
Soldatinnen und Soldaten sicher aus den
einsatzräumen nach Hause zurückzuholen
in einen entsprechenden medizinischen
Versorgung in Österreich zuzuführen um
Aufträge insbesondere internationalen
einsetzen erfüllen zu können muss das
österreichische Bundesheer befähigt sein
ein Patienten lufttransportsysteme
entsprechend auch autark betreiben zu
können
die luftschaltkräfte führten seit 2010
mit dem System Herkules 87 Meter
wegfliege durch
und vor allem in der covid-pandemie über
13 Einsätze wo wir kobit Patienten mit
entsprechenden Vorrichtungen sicher aus
dem Ausland zurückgeholt haben
es besteht jedoch mittlerweile
entsprechende Einschränkungen des
täglichen Betriebs aufgrund der
technischen Verfügbarkeit
die Herkules wie sie ja sehen als
Propellermaschine mit vier turops
passiert in allen Varianten auf einem
Grundkonzept aus dem 50er Jahren und
gerade mit der Erweiterung des
Aufgabenspektrums auf entfernte
Destination und Einsatzräume stößt die
Herkules somit immer mehr an ihre
Grenzen
umso mehr gilt es Ihnen meine Damen und
Herren der lufttransportstaffel der
fliegertechnischen Kompanie
der planungszelle operativer
Lufttransport und des
lufttransportumschlages sowie den
Kommando luftunterstützungen und meinen
Herrn in der Einsatzführung Luft wenn
Respekt mein Dank und meine besondere
Anerkennung
bevor jetzt zum letzten Abschluss kommt
möchte mich auch bei Militärkommandant
bedanken und insbesondere bei der
Militärmusik Oberösterreich für die
exzellente Ausführung des
fliegermarsches man spürt die hohe
fliegeraffinität am Fliegerhorst Vogler
herzlichen Dank geschätzte Kameraden
zum Abschluss eine wirklich gute
Nachricht noch vor dem Wochenende am
Montag dieser Woche hat im
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
der sogenannte luftgipfel stattgefunden
und der Führung vom Generalstabschef
genial Striedinger
und ich gehe davon aus dass unsere Frau
Bundesministerin Frau Magister Claudia
Tanner
zeitnahen eine Entscheidung für die
Nachfolger der C130 treffen wird
es leben die luftschaltkräfte es lebe
das österreichische Bundesheer Glück ab
gut Land
[Applaus]
die Rede des Herrn landesrats Dr
Wolfgang hartmannsdorfer wird
angekündigt durch das Stück oder mein
Österreich von Franz von super in dem
uns bekannten marschformat komponiert
von Ferdinand Preis 1852
[Musik]
ich bitte sie respektvoll um ihre Worte
sehr geehrte fest und Ehrengäste
hochgeschätzte Geistlichkeit die ihr
international guess one welcome to Apo
Austria the power harte powerstate auf
der Republic of Austria sehr geehrter
Herr schief sehr geehrter Kommandant der
Luftunterstützung Offiziere und
Offiziere Soldaten heute der Festakt 20
Jahre Herkules ist ein Tag der
Dankbarkeit ein Tag des Stolzes und vor
allem ein Tag des Respektes ein Tag des
Respektes vor ihrer Arbeit vor ihren
Einsätzen mit und rund um die Herkules
und das mittlerweile seit 20 Jahren und
es unterstreicht glaube ich auch die
Bedeutung des österreichischen
Bundesheers nicht nur in der
Verantwortung für die Sicherheit der
Republik in Österreich an den Grenzen zu
sorgen sondern auch die Verantwortung
des österreichischen Bundesheers im
Bereich der Sicherheit im Ausland auf
der einen Seite was die Ver Verarbeitung
betrifft bei humanitären Einsätzen aber
was auch die Verantwortung betrifft bei
sicherheitseinsätzen im Ausland und wie
wichtig das Engagement des
österreichischen Bundesheers im Ausland
ist merkt man gerade in Tagen in Wochen
wie diesen wo eine Tagesreise weg von
uns ein schrecklicher Krieg stattfindet
und dieser Krieg in der Ferne
unmittelbare Auswirkungen auf unsere
Republik auf die Republik Österreich hat
in banalen Fragen die wir tagtäglich
spüren was kostet der Strom Ausland
bedeutet eine moderne Sicherheitspolitik
auch sich vor den Grenzen Österreichs
engagieren und wir haben erst genau vor
einer Woche in Ried Teile der
Panzergrenadiere und auch andere
truppenfabs und deswegen ist da hinten
ist auch zu Militärstandort Hörsching
weil und das zeigen uns glaube ich die
Diskussionen der aktuellen Zeit dass
Freiheit das Demokratie in seinem freien
in seinem Liberalen Verständnis nur
möglich sein kann wenn ein Staat auch in
der Lage ist für die Sicherheit zu
sorgen und damit auch ein ganz ein
klares Bekenntnis zum österreichischen
Bundesheer und ich sage allen die die
Diskussion führen brauchen wir überhaupt
der Herkules brauchen wir Hubschrauber
braucht man kampflieger brauchen wir
überhaupt noch Kasernen schauen wir uns
um in dieser Welt ich glaube wer die
Gedanken aber bei uns ganz besonders
bedanken aber bei uns ganz besonders
auch beim Kommandanten der
Luftunterstützung dass auch das
Miteinander so gut funktioniert auf der
einen Seite direkt mit einer Beteiligung
von uns die man hinter der Herkules
sieht mit unserem Zivilflughafen aber
auch darüber hinaus mit dem Behörden und
ich hoffe dass diese heutige Festtag
einmal mehr bewusst macht die Bedeutung
die Wichtigkeit des österreichischen
Bundesheers die Bedeutung die
Wichtigkeit des Fliegerhorst Vogler und
ich darf schließen in Anlehnung an den
erdschiff es lebe das österreichische
Bundesheer es lebe unsere Heimat die
Republik Österreich
[Applaus]
[Musik]